[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front pages so time to
see what's making the headlines with the
daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and the Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine both with us from now until
just before midnight welcome to both of
you so as ever let's take a look at the
front pages then the eye reporting that
the Royal College of Nursing has upset
other unions with its willingness to
directly engage with the government over
strike action
The Daily Mirror meets Russian
mercenaries fighting on behalf of
Vladimir Putin in Ukraine
amid the current fruit and veg shortage
the Metro speaks to a little customer
who claims she was stopped from buying a
hundred cucumbers at once the headline
sees her salad
the star suggests that protests could
soon start if the shortages continue
they've had their own one as you can see
front of the telegraph carries a warning
from BT the telecoms giant claiming the
Chancellor's planned corporation tax
rise is a threat to investment and
growth
financial times has a report on the
tobacco firm Philip Morris's thus far
unsuccessful attempts to sell its
Russian assets
the guardian carries an investigation
into so-called forever chemicals which
enter the human body due to people's
external environment and then fail to
break down
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's head straight to Our Guest then
to Kevin McGuire and Sarah Vine and
certainly a day when the newspapers
don't quite agree on a lead story so
let's delve inside then and shall we
Sarah to the uh begum story she wants
her passport back the answer today was
no again and the question now is should
be should be seen as a child who was
trafficked or as someone who's a threat
to National Security
well she's really a test case isn't she
I think she's quite comp it's quite a
complex case because there's no doubt
that she was 15 when she went she did
however go on her own it wasn't as
though she was sort of bundled into the
back of a van and transported
um she was groomed in the UK she is or
was a British citizen born here
um but the truth is that she you know a
lot of a lot of people feel quite
strongly I mean I myself included that
what she did was uh actually atrocious
and the fact that you know when she was
interviewed a few years ago she she I'm
so sorry the cat is here
um she refused to
um condemn uh the people who blew up the
Manchester Stadium
um and that she sort of didn't seem to
express
um any real genuine regret for her
actions is problematic
um I think that this I I did this
attempt to sort of get her back on the
basis that she was you know groomed and
a child
doesn't really hold water every single
person I've spoken to who's had eyes on
the information about uh what she did
is does say that that you know she can't
come back for very good reasons so I
think it's a very difficult case and of
course if the government allow her back
then they open the open the gates to
lots of other people in similar
situations so it's very difficult thing
the problem is she she will remain
stateless and that is an issue because
she has to go somewhere she can't live
in a refugee camp for the rest of her
life so it's difficult yeah it is a
number of issues come out of this one
that dual citizenship doesn't seem to
help anybody
um Kevin the other one is of course that
the Kurds running this camp in Northern
Syria want people to go and thirdly you
know what is it that the special
immigration appeals commission hearing
knows that we don't the allegations for
example
um which people have asked her about to
be fair that she's stitched vests for
would-be suicide bombers
um you know carrying a rifle to enforce
dress codes and so on all of this sort
of stuff are they getting to hear that
should they explain more to us about the
decision behind this do you think
I think I think they should and we've
had briefings from from the home office
uh painting out in the way you've just
described and you know in answer to your
initial question uh is she a child who
was traffic yes could she be a threat to
National Security possibly but I think
it's a a bad day from uh for British
Justice when somebody who is born in
Britain uh lived in London groomed in
London uh is somehow discarded and just
disposed of because she doesn't have
dual nationality she hasn't got
Bangladesh in uh nationality her parents
may have uh been from Bangladesh
originally but she'd never been there
she doesn't have a passport and we've
made a stateless and we've dumped her on
the world in other countries are taking
back their Isis Fighters this this is
not to be a a fan boy for shameema bacon
she's committing any crime she should be
tried here and held accountable punished
in whatever way but it's this idea here
that you can just dump somebody and as
Tim Farren the former leader of the
liberal Democrat said if she was called
uh Sharon from Manchester and she was
white this wouldn't happen she wouldn't
have been treated in in this way which
is why uh I hope I actually hope the
appeal succeeds because I don't think
this is British Justice other countries
are taking back their Fighters there's
probably about 400 estimated people from
the UK who went and joined uh the
Islamic State which
concedes and admits was a terrorist
organization who've returned several
dozen of them have been prosecuted the
rest have just returned to to society
but she somehow has become a poster girl
for everybody who who wants to turn on
on anybody I'm not painting her out to
be an angel but it should have been
groomed in the same way and had gone off
to a group in say Sunderland Swansea or
Sterling instead of Syria she'd be back
she'd have been yes held accountable for
whatever she she did Sarah wants to come
in but then but then Social Services
would have intervened yeah so I don't I
don't think she's done herself any
favors by doing all of this sort of
publicity drive because you know she was
on the front cover of the Times magazine
a couple of weeks at weekends ago and it
sort of styled as though she was some
sort of supermodel you know alongside
you know headlines about recipes and
things it's just the whole that there's
a sense that she's sort of styling
herself as a kind of weird terrorist
celebrity and I think Ordinary People
find that rightly quite unpleasant Sarah
Sarah
she's been she's done a podcast for the
BBC she's not it's not right for
somebody that who has done what she has
done should have that kind of platform I
don't think that's right whether or not
right
you you will know as a journalist from a
refugee camp in the kurdish-controlled
part of Syria where the Kurds think she
should be returned to the UK and dealt
with she will have no control over how
she is presented in the times of paper
you work for you know that and I agree
in those early interviews about the
Manchester Arena where she was somewhere
uh you know almost Justified you know
explaining why the bomber had had done
what they did of course it was appalling
and didn't it didn't help and I'm not
giving her a clean bill of health or
putting her on a pedestal or anything
the fact is she was born in Britain she
was British she is British it's just
we've removed her passport and I think
it's absolutely wrong that we do that to
people and dump them on other countries
she's our responsibility for good or bad
well her legal team certainly saying it
is not over so we'll see what happens
but moving on if you don't mind to the
eye
um obviously some celebrations yesterday
that the nursing Union would finally
hold talks with the health secretary
other unions though are seriously not
happy about this Sarah
yeah I don't know why I mean if they
want to get their pay rise then they
need to talk to the health secretary say
why they cross somebody else is making a
Headway and they're not it was just
silly it's just pointless sort of
posturing I mean it just shows that
they're not doing it for any sense of
reason other than to just cause trouble
yeah Kevin I mean I note that the eye is
saying the government blinked first on
this to be fair carry on yeah although
although you know Pat color of the Royal
College of Nursing for a long time had
been saying if the government offered
meaningful talks the strikes would be
suspended but there's no other
government and we'll meet them halfway
on in terms of what we what we require
anyway yeah carry on and it's backed off
on its insistence that everything had to
be done through the peer review body and
it wouldn't reopen this year's
settlement will be next year's Steve
Bartley the health secretary had been
pushing for some time to be able to make
a new offer but the treasury the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak were blocking him
but I can see why other unions are
cheesed off should we say that the
conservative party is fine highly
remembered how to divide and Rule which
has kept it in power for most part of
the last uh that last three questions
it's because they're excluded and it's
there those are the unions representing
nurses aren't involved and then of
course there's a looks like there might
be a deal done with the nurses but what
about ambulance workers Junior doctors
in the NHS what about teachers what
about civil servants of the people
across the uh the economy no I can I can
see why the government's doing this I've
been surprised politically they haven't
done it a lot earlier and of course we
normally talk about the king's Shilling
I suppose whoever this described as a
bitter Union official on the front page
of the eye there's no name there I don't
know if there's a name inside talking
about the king's farting is there's a
clearly they'll be in a TUC affiliate
Trade union and the fear the Royal
College of Nursing which isn't part of
the TUC will settle for for something
they wouldn't and then put great
pressure on them I think I think that's
what it is but yeah the government is
remembered how a dividing rule okay um
to the Daily Telegraph now tax it's been
a big issue has it not uh for the
conservative party
um and this is I suppose all ahead of
the upcoming budget effectively but BT
now one of those bigger organizations
telling the chancellor that the planned
corporation tax rise is a threat to
investment and growth
um that was one of the tax changes that
was in Liz truss's sides of course back
in the day Sarah
yes I'm in the corporation tax will rise
with 19 to 25 in April which is a big
jump
um of course it will put big companies
which like big profits like BT who could
by the way if they're listening because
you make my Wi-Fi work please for which
I pay you for
um I don't like that kind of thing
because it means that it's you know that
they can't make the sort of money they
need I mean you know it's a delicate
Balancing Act between getting getting uh
sufficient uh receipts for the revenue
and uh not pricing out companies that
will want to invest in this country
um whether or not uh he's got it right
we'll we'll have to we'll have to see a
lot of people think he hasn't a lot of
things people think that this will will
put growth off in this country
um well I mean this is this this whole
tax versus growth has been a fascinating
debate has it not and no doubt will be
studied I think presumably
um but the problem is that that the
demands in all public sector areas are
so great now that surely having tax is
the only way to pay for them right now
while growth as we know is stalled Kevin
oh yeah look and uh 25 uh corporation
tax and we're basically canceling a cut
down to 19 the UK's corporation tax rate
will still be amongst the the lowest of
any major industrial uh country it might
even be the lowest of the G7 and it's
sort of be higher in France Germany the
us so I think BT I can see why they're
special pleading I don't I don't uh
you know Grumble about that that's what
they're going to do as a corporation
they just want more more money will it
really uh affect their investment I
suspect not and otherwise they'll be
cutting off their nose to spite their
face and I do do remember BT as a
privatized company moaning about the
windfall tax back in 1997 when labor was
coming up for a five billion windfall
attack against gas water electricity BT
to fund a jobs program for young people
who have been claiming that the world
would collapse uh and it never did uh
well coming up after break we will be
discussing uh David Bowie is quite
extraordinary outfits which make many a
front page and also as the fruit and veg
shortage continues we will ponder why
anyone would need to buy 100 cucumbers
at once but that when we come back
foreign
[Music]
with me once again as you can see Kevin
McGuire and Sarah Vine now sees her
salad front page of the Metro uh the
woman Sarah who decided to purchase
we're told 100 cucumbers in her trolley
we're not sure why I think maybe she
runs a Greek restaurant is making
Tzatziki or maybe relish I'm not sure
but maybe there's a good explanation but
the problem is how long will this
continue and how many more items will be
added to the missing list I guess
because I think we just should give a
shout out to the headline writer because
Caesar salad is very good I have to say
it's very very good I don't know why
would anyone want 100 cucumbers yeah
there's a fruit and veg shortage uh
fresh fruit and veg short as I should
say you can still get plenty of Frozen
which I you know is is it or is an
option although bad it's not for salad
um and also I read this week that uh
asparagus season has come early in this
country so maybe we could have some of
that but yes there is a fruit and veg a
shortage um it's to do with a number of
things whether uh bad weather
um you know General kind of sort of
supply line problems
um and people are as ever overreacting I
think I mean
there are a hundred cucumbers in the
shops it's not as though there are no
cucumbers it's just that you can't have
all 100.
absolutely uh Daily Star has managed its
own campaign I can't tell if that's a
tomato or it is a tomato isn't it yeah
it's a tomato I was going to say it's
Mandarin
protesting on his own at Westminster
um but uh certainly Therese coffee the
environment secretary
um was speaking at the national Farmers
Union today
um suggesting that the uh that they
can't be responsible for or we can't
control the weather in Spain which
didn't seem to go down too well because
a lot of this is energy costs of our own
domestic
um Queen greenhouses or glass houses
isn't it uh Kevin
yeah I think every time his coffee opens
her mouth she puts her foot in it and it
didn't uh you know show much sympathy to
domestic Growers who are facing us
higher energy costs the the woman on the
front of the the Metro is a personal
trainer
um uh and I uh what's her name uh Lisa
Lisa fans and she was stopping a little
because she was buying 100 cucumbers
because she makes a lot of drinks for
people I think uh not just for herself
but she but she trains but you're you're
right brexit supply lines being
disrupted maybe a factor because other
parts of Europe seem have no problems
but it you know the bad weather and the
uh south on the Mediterranean in North
Africa is a fact there and then in the
UK huge costs uh huge energy Rises
because of the way we have this energy
market and we're paying more more than
many other countries so those domestic
Growers uh haven't haven't been growing
uh um so much salad but I suspect now
prices are soaring they'll be uh turning
up the heat and uh cashing in that's
what unexpected yeah it rather pains you
as a parent who spent years trying to
get my kids to eat salad now they'd have
a very valid reason yeah there's still
carrots around I presume my kids love
carrots and other root vegetables
they're not so keen on but anyway we're
seeing when we can persuade them to eat
my son obsessed with cucumbers it's all
he likes that's that's the only
vegetable he'll eat is cucumbers so
we'll have to go shopping every day and
just purchase one at a time that's the
answer let's talk about the pictures
some wings
in and outs you know
she might be found out anyway we'll see
um the the ft and the Telegraph and in
fact I think I can't remember which one
it was was it the guardian uh picturing
uh David Bowie in his Fantastical
outfits
um the subject of a new flamboyant uh
Victoria and Albert Museum show
um what a look that will be Sarah
I mean it'll just be completely
oversubscribed I think I'll probably
have to go back 25 times also is it
Bowie or Bowie I think I think we should
be told I don't know but he is I mean he
was just iconic and the outfits are just
I mean he you know he was really uh he
was just about the as much about the
image as he was about the music and this
is going to be a fantastic show
absolutely you that that image on the
front of the Ft the black and the the
whites it's kind of striped it's a
that's what's uh Sam Smith hasn't uh
must have ripped off for the for the
Brits when he had a a black inflatable
outfit but like that that's 1973 that
costume he was ahead of his time
absolutely fantastic the style I icon
yeah absolutely uh both of you lovely to
have you on see you for the 11th thank
you very much indeed